[Music]
okay yeah
we're all good everyone's good all right
today
special episode special guest it is he
the logical
leftist because we do need at least one
doctor of philosophy author of a book on
arguments for the left and of course
podcast dude he's the host of
give them an argument it is ben burgess
on the pill pod also twitter famous
we should mention the things that matter
how's it going ben
uh i'm pretty good uh so i was actually
as we were recording
we're getting ready to record this i was
originally thinking i was going to uh
go down to uh drive down east lansing
today which would have complicated the
schedule
uh which where my parents live but uh i
did not since i have what i'm pretty
sure is a mild cold but we live in a
very exciting time when uh
you know a mild cold could be a mild
cold or it could be something else but
i'm pretty sure it's just a mild cold
yeah i was on the bus not too long ago
and some guy sneezed
and the woman next to us panicked she
was like
why the hell is he doing that is he
wearing a mask we got somebody in here
and i was like you know
people do sneeze it does happen right
you know it gives a totally new meaning
to you know julius chris
or julia christeva's abject
any abject is like an object of fear
yeah and your excretions and your
expulsions
because it could be the covet-laced
spittle anyway we do
have a philosophy in the subtitle of
this podcast however there is a kind of
philosophy
that we have so far pretended does not
exist
it is known as analytic or
anglo-american
which is more commonly the method that
you find
in universities so we've been uh
kind of irresponsible matt and i have
done a rawls episode
yeah we've done rawls and a couple of
other people who like
flirt with that tradition but that's
analytical political theory it's not
really true
hard analytical philosophy you know the
crypt gaze
and you know continental philosophy
suggests there's a body of water you
have to cross before you find these
people
right it does although it's funny
because um
you know traces back to a
card app and and the vienna circle
and so those are obviously uh europeans
remember uh brian leiter uh has a uh
making a joke somewhere about how the
two people who did the most for the
quality of academic philosophy in
america were adolf hitler and margaret
thatcher you know
hitler because of course that caused so
many philosophers to flee
and uh thatcher just by like cutting
university budgets so you know people
have more of an incentive to get jobs in
the united states
absolutely checks out also i think there
was uh you know
a lot of people what they would think of
as the sort of break between
what we think of as continental and
analytic too a lot of people i don't
think know that
edmund herseral right the first
phenomenologist he used to
be pretty tight with um you know the
people who the person they call the
father of analytic god
why is his name escaping me fraga that's
it yeah fraga and husserl used to
correspond and write letters back and
forth
and uh they they initially started off
with similar positions but kind of took
different paths
i mean i think one one thing that really
complicates this
is that it's really unclear what if
anything the term analytic philosophy
actually refers to
uh since it certainly can't be the name
of a position
people who want to write clearly yeah
it's a style i mean honestly i think
that is at this point you know what what
very little meaning that phrase still
has
i think is uh is largely about that
right because
of course uh there are you know tons of
people we think it was analytic
philosophers who
who think that you know about the
incredibly esoteric issues that you know
who's role and
uh and frank were argued about that
whose role was more right than fraga
uh there's there's no um i mean the
actual break
uh really i think comes you know with um
you know with with heidegger you know i
think that like a lot of people we would
think of as early analytic philosophers
uh reaction to uh you know to being in
time
you know is is like a lot of what sort
of makes the uh the sense that there are
now two different kinds of philosophy
going on
but then like there are tons of analytic
philosophers now who
who like are are interested in heidegger
and and like mine like you know
like interesting things to say about
philosophy of mind or whatever out of
heidegger
uh so so it's clearly not you know a
position
the uh the geographical division which
is
you know which is what's suggested by
you know the name continental philosophy
is also a little funny since again uh
most
you know like a big part of you know
analytics philosophy comes from
continental europe
um although i guess you could say there
that may be part of this separation is
that
um you know it's the heidegger you know
not to put too fine a point on it could
stay in europe
uh you know whereas the uh the often
jewish often socialist you know analytic
philosophers could not
uh and although i will also say fraga
had lived long enough i think that he
would have
he would have been the same kind of
embarrassment to uh to analytic
philosophy quite likely you know he was
like pretty nationalistic and pretty
anti-semitic and you know so i
i think there's a at least a 50 50
chance he would have become a nazi you
know if he had a chance
we're not genetically drifted enough
that there can't be some uh
inter-breeding still of course uh de luz
wrote on whitehead a lot i actually
actually have a take on this which is
which is probably like poorly informed
and probably wrong
uh but uh go for it i'm gonna share it
anyway
so that's what we're about
which is that um like the actual
content certainly of deluse's meta
philosophy
like actually honestly has always just
struck me as like
pretty much late card app like i think
that it's it's kind of
like i think to lose is kind of it's
very nominalistic yeah yeah like like
like the way he talks about like you
know creating you know concepts and all
that stuff like it's it's very much like
the kardap stuff about
conceptual frameworks so i think that it
sort of
feel like the i think the ideas are very
similar but it just kind of feels the
same niche for people who
uh have a stylistic preference for you
know reading philosophy
you know in translation and you know
with like a little whiff of obscurity
about it
if you really wanted to find somebody
who said
well language is indeterminate and we
need to be semantic holist
we need to recognize that the
representational picture of how is that
words what you
work uh is actually false you don't need
to go to daredevil or even for co
you can just go to quine wittgenstein
any number of other major figures
davidson davidson yeah and you'll find
very similar arguments uh to my mind
just presented with a lot more clarity
uh and a little bit less pretention
i will say that um that uh i think that
quine i think is probably the most like
uh
as far as writing style goes i think
quiet is probably the most continental
analytic philosopher ever
oh we want to get to your origin story a
little bit ben
because our our listeners know about the
choices that we faced in coming to
where we are but you took a a different
fork or a different path on the fork
that we did on the journey to
wisdom so what is it that drove you into
the arms of formal logic
i guess considering that so much of at
least 20th century philosophy
um i guess ben's continental i know
we're kind of
obfuscating that actual division but
what what made you
a formal analytic philosopher so
really i wouldn't overestimate the
degree to which it was a choice although
it sort of was
like you're you were talking about um
uh who was it what's her name chris deva
earlier
and and and i do have some damn
unpleasant memories of having to read
that as an undergraduate and
uh just thinking this is just
indecipherable nonsense what's
going on here um which is probably
unfair i'm sure if i read it again now
you know i'd i'd have a different take
on it but you know certainly
you know certainly my impression then um
so i i guess so so
i guess it is probably true that i
didn't like
even though i wasn't thinking about it
in those terms like i'm making some big
choice here about like camps of
philosophy or anything like that
i was just sort of following what felt
like the path of least resistance i'm
sure there is like a buried choice there
since
since i did you know i mean i did take
some
you know well one really undergraduate
class uh
where i was exposed to a lot of that
stuff i remember reading
uh the was it uh derek uh the uh the
gift of death
and um and i had to do a presentation on
it was a seminar
and i remember just thinking this is
like this crazy emperor's new clothes
moment because like i knew that i didn't
know what i was talking about
like that i was i was just like reading
something in so i have something to say
but nobody called me on it not even the
professor
so did i ever tell you about this funny
anecdote i deployed at birkbeck
when i was at the critical theory summer
school there so there was a hegelian
camp and a delusion camp
and i know i knew at the time you know
quite a bit about both of those but
what i realized is the way to impress
both of them is whenever someone gives
an interpretation
step in and just say yeah i think that
there's a lot that's why i do it but i
think we need to give an even more
radical interpretation of that
and make sure you emphasize the radical
and make the hand and then just talk
about how it is that
not only do they talk as their theory
encompassed this but it actually
covers whole new domains of thought that
we even that we even knew about
and everybody will agree with you just
because they're like well of course i
can't
deny a more radical interpretation of
this right you know matt you are just
giving away the game here
yeah so that that is probably like i
think that probably does
like that anecdote probably does get
down to like a
a temperament difference for for why you
know that
for why it never really occurred to me
to
pursue that it didn't feel like a
conscious choice but also i think
in terms of yeah i think in terms of
temperament you're right i i probably do
gravitate towards
uh you know not doing things in the way
that that just described
but it's not it's fun though because i
mean wait what i noticed
whenever i would say that it would be
like a more radical interpretation still
of delusion blah blah blah or
galleon dialectable it was amazing how
quickly they would all fall into line
about it just
like oh yeah i never really thought of
it that way and i actually started
experiment by saying things that were
completely nonsensical and even
inventing like
whole paragraphs of text that just
sounded really really smart
and some people would actually continue
to fall in line with it as long as it
sounded
airy and impressive or they're just too
polite to call you on it which is why
i'm biting my tongue now because we have
to get to our actual topic
rather than rather than am i correcting
you
well look i will say
i mean i think they're certainly like so
i i get i think it's a matter of
temperament i don't
like like i i don't think i do well in
that environment that you're describing
but i also
i also think that there's like a lot of
stuff that happens in
alec philosophy that's that's kind of
silly in a different way
right um people
imitating the structure of how
um of how like hard sciences you know
journals work you know that you think
you sort of do these
these very very small things that you
know that are supposed to build on each
other
it's like the only reason people are
doing it that way is because like
you know that feels like the rigorous
way to do it because in these other
disciplines where it actually makes
sense
you know people people do it that way
but you're not actually getting anything
from limiting the scope of your
you know of your inquiry to this to
these like super tiny niche subjects
that you know you've read all
500 papers that have been written on and
you can make one tiny little point about
it you know that there's no actual
like real justification you know for
doing it that way so i i think that's
like the thing that's often
silly about analytic philosophy uh this
is the one thing that i found most
obnoxious about analytical philosophy
just to be fair since i took some pot
shots on the continental side
i like to do a little of both so i'm
saying this partly in just you know um
you know it's one of those you know
jokes with love right but um
one of the things i find frustrating
about analytical philosophers is how
uptight
and tight-ass they are about what counts
as real philosophy
you know there's an article i read about
by john caputo where he's like
is darada even a real philosopher and
the big put down
at the end is maybe but i think he
mostly belongs in
god forbid english departments right and
this is this kind of thing that's like
really so you know you're not willing to
say it's philosophy it's literary theory
or it's cultural theory or something
else
and i'm like this kind of uh
disciplinary policing just seemed to me
very pretentious and not a really good
look
for philosophy especially when you think
back to somebody like plato who
or socrates right who was very happy to
talk about [ __ ] everything
you know what i mean yeah no i'm totally
with you there i
i think um i mean look my position
is uh yeah certainly
you know certainly you know certainly
darada is a
philosopher and that's not even like to
say anything nice about daredevil i mean
like that's just like he's like yeah
whatever i mean
he's obviously he's writing about
philosophical issues if you're gonna
try to have any sort of definition um
you know like an actual definition and
not just accept that it's a family
resemblance term which
is probably the right way to go then
that's surely the definition right you
know like like like i mean whatever ayn
rand is a philosopher she's not a good
philosopher but she's a philosopher
yeah i mean my supervisor once pointed
out that one of the reasons we people we
talk about
political theory versus and political
science versus political philosophy
even though it's called political
philosophy for a really long time uh
with some analytical philosophers in the
1950s got tight asked again about it
because they're like
well ethics morality politics that's not
things that real philosophers deal with
real philosophers are
epistemologists or logicians and that's
the kind of fruity stuff that
which is interesting that is the origin
story because now
uh i think the only people i see
enforcing that one are political
scientists
since uh you know like uh i mean and
and actually despite what i just said
like i'm uh
i've got enough of that like sort of
some weird irrational thing in the back
of my mind getting me to give a [ __ ]
about this uh that like i'm constantly
annoyed by that right you know like i'll
see
you know even somebody i really like you
know corey robin whoever regular like
sort of uh described like
i remember he had a uh he had a post a
while ago where he was talking about
biographies of political theorists and
why they weren't any good and he was
like
you know people write good biographies
of this and that and that and
philosophers
and then it's like and then again it's
it's deeply stupid that i would care
about this but
uh but i do so uh
and then like the people he was listed
off as political theorists like oh those
are [ __ ] philosophers what are you
talking about right they
they they taught in philosophy
departments they're doing what's you
know what everybody would refer to as
you know
philosophy and um i don't know i mean
like that it like
what you're talking about is also i
think like a very brief temporal window
you know i mean i'm pretty sure that
like if we actually i don't i guess i
haven't seen these numbers so i could be
wrong but you know if we
if we actually like did a survey of
people who
would generally be considered to be you
know
of philosophy professors who would
generally be considered to be analytic
philosophers
my you know strong guess would be that
like more of them are doing like
uh moral and political philosophy than
anything else
just just just because you know just
because most normal human beings
you know are are probably just more
interested you know in that than than in
you know philosophy of language or any
of that stuff
um or epistemology i was gonna say
episode epistemology
is right now that's what drove me out of
analytic philosophy the second i read a
gettier case
and it was like if you walk past a room
and you believe someone's in the room
you accidentally are looking at a
hologram and you don't know
yet you believe that the person is in
the room do you have knowledge
that that person's in the room or not
that's that's what it's
anyway it's not a giddyur case it's a
fake barn case you know
just you know you've got to get this
this straight it's very important
why would we doubt in our philosophy
what we do not doubt in our hearts i
like uh
i like charles purse on that one all
right so if you want to know
any of ben's views on
2021 he has a youtube channel and he has
a podcast
uh we didn't we didn't want to invite
him there to talk about
or invite him here excuse me to discuss
that however because i thought we could
do something a little more fun
something that you probably get to talk
about less often
um and this is probably due to our
roughly similar age as uh millennials as
opposed to
probably most of our audience
but let me bring you back to 2003
the arise of the very first debate lords
debate lords often used as a pejorative
but the four horsemen dawkins
harris sam harris he's actually still
around
christopher hitchens yeah other than
hitches all of them were around
and i'm blanking on the fourth someone
oh
damn it the the philosophy of mind
analytic philosophy of mind
yeah he's around well i actually kind of
like even if i find his writing
obnoxious but
yeah i think i thought it is yes also
dub the four horsemen of the new atheist
right that's right yep and the reason
that i would i wanted to
invite ben here for this is because ben
uh
engages with the current generation of
debate lords
i'm not exactly sure sure who they all
are i know destiny is one
victor victor showed me some uh destiny
videos
but we want to we want to take you back
from 2003 to present
and give you a chronicle of debate
lordism
with ben yeah so i guess
i feel like um
yeah 2003 is probably as good as
anything uh
you know although i i think that yeah i
mean the
the sort of big new atheist books i
think tended to come around around 2007
2008 uh feel like uh
like certainly that's when god is not
great came out
um there was uh dawkins of course the
uh the god delusion which
uh maybe that was earlier okay yeah
those two just a fun
thing that i randomly happen to have
found out uh today is that uh
christopher hitchens never read
dawkins book he said he tried to but he
couldn't get through it
[Laughter]
yeah which then also he apparently told
the interviewer not to
not to mention that in the published
version of the
interview since he didn't want to sour
his uh his relationship with him
uh but i would but i i tend to think
that's
that's like a telling detail since um
i i think that uh you know i think the
hitchens despite his
his many terrible you know late in life
positions
uh on you know uh war and terrorism and
all that stuff
uh i think was was still just a you know
a much more interesting person
and writer you know that i would have
[ __ ] killed to get a drink with that
dude
killed well actually also uh a uh
another random
um so i i recently talked to
uh somebody who did uh do uh do quite a
bit of that
uh that uh who was uh a uh
a student of uh actually oddly enough
both hitchens and g-shack at the
new school uh and uh
and so he he told me some you know some
stories about drinking with hitchens and
whatnot
and uh and in the uh the course of that
he actually said something which is just
like
you know for anybody who does uh have
the
you know the perverse affection for the
milo that you're asking me about that i
do
is is like a real like lost you know
um you know heartache and loss for
youtube you know which is that
uh apparently uh at one point he
uh he was trying to get the two of them
to uh do a debate about the iraq war and
both of them
both of them said yes uh and uh
but then like they couldn't make the
schedules work and then you know the
intentions got sick
uh but there was almost a hitchens
reject debate about iraq
seems like it would have been youtube
gold but um
right yeah they were the original owners
yeah right so of course this is um
you know i think thinking about you know
hitchins and dawkins and harris and
bennett
and dead it always seems like kind of
the odd man out there since
and i think in fact from what i can tell
i think that he has kind of
de-emphasized that kind of thing
in recent years like i think he might
have just sort of
gone back to just kind of quietly being
a superstar philosophy professor instead
of
instead of having that you know anything
like the sort of role that he had
in the four horsemen and and honestly
even in the four horsemen role
you know he was always a little
forgettable uh you know like like and
whatever i mean that's not that's not a
slam on on bennett i
i actually think that dennett is in some
ways yeah you know
like certainly he was operating in a
different intellectual league than
certainly i'd say sam harris uh and i
would definitely say also for that
matter richard dawkins if richard
dawkins isn't talking about biology
right
yeah for sure i mean there are um
like yeah i mean there are things i find
very frustrating about daddy's writing
but you know he's clearly like
10 000 times smarter than sam harris no
no doubt whatsoever about that
and and i think that hitchens is a more
interesting writer than bennett but i
also think that you know daddy is a much
more rigorous you know thinker than
anyone has no doubt about that
um but yeah and dawkins for
for sure i mean he like yeah he's he's a
he's a good he's a good writer he's a
good like popularizer of biology
but anytime he tries to do philosophy
it's just a weird mess
uh like like like i saw him speak it um
university of miami you know which is
where i did my phd program
uh i don't know back in like 2013 or
something
and uh and actually before you know he
did like a couple of speaking
engagements while i was there and then
he also did this thing where he just
uh you know he sat down with the uh
you know philosophy department for a
little discussion but i think this is
actually at the uh the big speaking
engagement which was
which is funny right because that's it's
dawkins he's a big draw so it's like a
giant auditorium in fact i think there
were some
overflow auditoriums where you could see
him on a you know
huge screen like you know like you're
you're watching you know big brother in
1984 or something
and there was a point in the q a i was
gonna say like a pastor at one of those
mega churches
yeah yeah that's right that's right yeah
which is
which does get to one of the things that
most annoys me uh about all those guys
but dawkins in particular because he was
popularizing like the
little a pin for you know atheist which
which really struck me as like
you know jesus christ you know i i got
uh you know
takes like if you if you turn atheism
into a religion then you know then like
really like you you
seems to me that you've uh you've
negated most of the human benefit of
that but
uh but in the q a
after this talk um somebody was asking
him about
uh his support for the grade 8 project
with peter singer
and some other people which is this this
effort which is a you know i should say
i think a laudable thing i like it i
support it you know i mean not that i've
ever done anything to support it but you
know
possibly verbally i support it right now
you know i'm sympathetic to it i guess
that's the way to put it you know to
uh to try to get like some of the uh the
great apes that are you know that
uh are are like very close to human
intelligence and stuff like that you
know have like some like more
legal rights you know recognize which
you know what strikes me as a fine and
reasonably noble thing but uh i don't
know i remember i watched the uh the
rise to the planet of the apes movie and
uh
and and i have to say i came out of it
very pro-ap you know the uh
they didn't want all that to happen they
should have been nicer to the apes no
justice no peace but uh
i i think a different attack i think it
shows why it is that we need to
crush down on the sapience from the very
beginning right you can't allow these
stirrings of rebellion to begin
yeah i think you've been reading too
many of those uh conservative authors
for your
stuff about them but uh but yeah so in
um while he was talking about that
though like his argument for why
we should you know recognize more rights
for you know for the great apes was like
the worst argument ever it was just
bizarre it was uh
uh he said well imagine and he did this
like
super like goofy poetic thought
experiments like imagine that you had
uh you know you were you're standing at
a lake i don't know why
you know whatever like it was a at the
edge of a lake you're holding hands with
your mother and she's holding hands with
her mother and her mother and her mother
her mother
going back to the nearest common
ancestor with the great apes and then
you go back up to them in the other
direction
well any two links in this chain uh
it would be impossible to uh to to make
meaningful differentiations between
they'd be too similar
and as a uh as a
flourish for this you know he said it
would uh you'd have to be making
distinctions as arbitrary
you know as as the racial laws of
apartheid south africa
and even ignoring that last part it's
like okay
yeah i'm sure that's true right that you
have 82 links in the chain
are too similar to each other to um you
know to
to make like a big okay this is where we
draw the line you know this is a person
and this isn't fair enough
but come on now richard you could
what if the chain of mothers you know by
the hallmark lake
uh went back to they uh went back to an
amoeba
right like couldn't you make the same
[ __ ] argument there you know that
they
uh that you know that any two links in
the chain are gonna be so similar to
each other that you're not gonna know
where to draw the line
uh and you know this is just the uh
you know this is just the uh the the
continuum fallacy that you know that
we it's there are you know um gray area
cases therefore there's no real
distinction it's like saying that you
know you could
um that you know you could take
somebody who had zero harris on his head
is bald
uh and you could add a hair and add a
hair and add a hair and add a hair until
he had a head of hair like fabio
okay but clearly where's
where's the what are the exact numbers
of hairs he has to have on his head for
him to not be bald
and good luck answering that question
right like okay you know it's exactly 10
437 hairs right that's obviously you're
not going to be able to draw a day
precise way but that doesn't mean that
there aren't clear cases of baldness
and clear cases of not baldness so all
of which is just to say
i think that dawkins is somebody who
when he goes outside of biology
it's just like what why are we listening
to this guy this
like he doesn't contra points had a
really good comment about her all's
sorry about dawkins also because his
atheism isn't even all that interesting
like nietzsche's atheism
is interesting marx's atheism is
interesting because they both diagnose
the consequences of declining belief
or belief structures in an interesting
way uh
whereas she points out that you know
with dawkins you're kind of just like
okay there is no god
according to him i should just leave my
life as normal and try to be happy
that's it and she points out that it's
no surprise that this movement kind of
wound down because there's only so many
different ways in which you can say that
before people are like
okay i get it no god spaghetti monster
you know go live my life and apparently
become a utility maximizer since that's
obviously the only thing to do
all right yeah i mean i mean i think
that i mean i'd even go a step
further i have a more radical
interpretation
utility maximizer your your choices are
just to have whatever ethical theory
you're gonna have that the two subjects
you know the one subject really tells us
very little about the other but then
like when you realize that
then that makes you know capital a
atheism atheism is a movement even more
pointless
if we can divert a little bit i'll throw
this to you victor because i know you
have thoughts on it but if we can divert
from
the content of what these guys were
actually talking about
and then pay attention to the form and
the media form because
youtube came out in like what 2005.
and then early youtube um when we were
we were
20 year olds uh dumbasses
but early youtube was very much
populated the very first
uh montages of people getting owned
was you know richard dawkins talks to
news host or richard dawkins
talks to creationist and this whole
window has shifted
to now it's uh you know shapido
or whatever the rest of the [ __ ] they
are
so these these collaboration owns um
and then this also evolves into a form
of debate
which uh yeah and burgess you
participated but there's these
visualized or televised
live debates where you get the groups of
fans
in and then each takes a side and then
we
we have we have sort of a spectacle or a
theater of debate
um fans ownings destruction and i just
wanted to see or
under or know how you saw that
transition going from
christians versus atheists or atheists
versus muslims
into sort of the political schism
that it's taken on now in the form that
we have now yeah
one of the funniest things is the very
first youtube video i ever saw about
politics was actually
o'reilly versus dawkins it's so funny
that's a good one i forgot about it and
like
i actually kind of like dawkins in that
not really yeah what he's saying but
just because i really
held just o'reilly and such contempt at
this point that see him struggle a
little bit
oh o'reilly got so mad in that clip
that's a great clip
if it's the one i'm thinking of then
yeah no that's a great but i think i
just
just just to add one other thing is i
think what's interesting is is the way
that like the the the transition to like
more recent political is like the the
invocation
of the logic and reason category right
that i think like stefan molyneux uses
all the time right so i think that's
just like another interesting detail
like the
like weaponization or the use of that of
that category of sign of like reason and
logic
yeah so uh i i do feel you on the uh
the o'reilly dawkins thing by the way
that there's there's no
like like there's no way to make you
like the uh the worst person that you
know to then to put them in the same
room as
somebody's worse than him so
like like the the standout example is to
my mind is you know
i've already talked a bunch about like
how much i
you know like dislike is even the right
word just just like loathe you know sam
harris but
um but if you uh listen to
uh the uh the very first time that
jordan peterson was on uh i think it was
called waking up at that point
um that's uh harris's podcast like
man like man i like harris after
listening to that you know
yeah you know it's just like
i don't know i mean like the whole thing
is just like harris
as as like an okay like philosophy
professor basically in that you know
in that role trying to explain something
like mind-numbingly basic to the world's
most confused undergrad
like it's like yes but even if you did
bad things on the basis of knowledge it
would still be true
right you know and like sort of like not
even you know like like
peterson's so all over the place like he
can't even engage with the question but
yeah
uh look i think that i think that the
invention of youtube is definitely
i mean it's kind of funny like it almost
makes uh
reminds me of that like was it like uh
mark says somewhere that like the uh
was it the uh the water wheel or
whatever it is i might even be missing
the medieval technology that like once
you have that you know that feudalism is
the form of society that's that's going
to be adapted to it
and then when you have the factory you
know capitalism you know
and uh and it's almost the same thing
right that once you have
uh once you have youtube you know the
debate lord is
is the is the kind of creature that's
you know that's naturally adapted to
that
and then you know once you have twitch
then you have the uh the the new
you know much more ridiculous version
that's you know that's that's the
natural entity for it but um but yeah i
i mean i think that uh it's
definitely like
this i think that that convergence that
there was this period of time when
people were
when when like atheism versus theism was
was really hot stuff
uh and it's it's not of course that you
know most people still don't find that
maybe interested to some extent or
interesting when they first think about
it you know but
but it was but it was like had a kind of
cultural currency for several years
there
in the 2000s that that really hasn't you
know
um you know before certainly since
uh and they and i think that that's
yeah i think the fact that that is the
era when we first got youtube
i think that's not coincidental and it
kind of goes back to
to what matt was saying about how you
know there are only so many ways to uh
you know if if you're if your point is
just like okay god probably doesn't
exist and you know that's okay we can
still live good lives blah blah
that there are only so many ways to say
this right you know that the two are
related because it's not so much that
the
uh you know the substance of it is uh
was
was the big appeal i mean it was part of
the appeal that you know people were
i'm sure tons of people did like you
know
hear hitchens or dawkins or whoever you
know making points they'd never thought
of it was really interesting to them
but mostly uh it's something that was a
really emotionally charged subject
that gave people a chance to do what
youtube is really good for you know that
that first
youtube video you were saying you
watched the uh o'reilly um
you know o'reilly dawkins uh like what
why is that good you know it's because
like like what's fun about it it's it's
spectacle it's it's
it's it's it's like almost like
rhetorical pro wrestling
uh which is which is what a lot of a lot
of youtube debate
is um i mean i i'm i mean obviously you
know since i
somebody partakes of it you know i mean
i i hold out hope that that's not
all that it could be but it is certainly
a big part of what it is i don't think
there's any
any doubt whatsoever about that uh and
so so yeah i think getting to see
like it's not a coincidence that two of
these four guys who've been talking
about the four horsemen
have british accents
you know i mean like that's something
that i think as americans especially you
know to the primary audience
you know we're primed to uh you know
especially that kind of
you know oxford cambridge you know kind
of
kind of accent uh you get a word same in
canada right you hear it and you just
think my colonial master right
a lot of credibility we instantly trust
them when they have a british accent
yeah
yeah which which i think actually you
know hitchens admitted to friends that
he even like sort of played up to the
poshness of his accent you know because
he knew
you knew that americans you know were
just suckers for that uh
and so um you know which
which i guess actually also makes sense
because he was he was kind of in uh
arivist you know he'd uh
you know he came from you know a solidly
middle-class family
but you know but he and he went to well
what in the us we call
private schools you know and uh and then
uh and then oxford
but uh but you know it's not like he was
it's not like he
uh you know he grew up quite in that
environment
uh but uh but yeah that like upper-class
british accents
i think are something that are you know
exciting to americans we take things
that people say with that accent more
seriously
they seem more interesting to us uh and
so
because that medium it's you know audio
visual you know that's that
that really that really helps uh that's
that's a big uh
you know that's that's a big asset and
so and
even with like hitchens who i think um
in a lot of ways i think like the last
10 years of his life
you know 2001 to 2011 were were the
least interested in
you know what like just even aside from
what i think about them politically
right i think i think the the years in
which
i really think objectively like what
he's saying is the least interesting
you know compared to uh everything that
he had written you know from like 1971
which is the first time that uh his name
is on the cover of a book the book by
the way
is a collection of essays by karl marx
about the paris commune with an
introduction by christopher hitchens
um to uh 2001 you know those those first
uh those first 30 years you know i think
he was writing much more interesting
things
but uh but what youtube really rewarded
was the side of him that was like
fun and a little pompous
and had a little bean and you know yeah
i mean they
came up with the neoligism for him
that's still around what was it uh hitch
slapped that's the one hitch slapping
hitch slapped exactly so uh so that's
what all of these clips are
and and i think this in terms of really
getting into what's being asked about in
terms of
um the genealogy of debate lords i think
this is a really crucial point because
if you watch any of those hitch slap
compilations on youtube
you're not really seeing much argument
like um
a little bit right but a lot of them are
basically just
somebody saying something and hitchens
like really laying
his accent on thick uh you know just
just just kind of
scolding them in a really rhetorically
effective way
you know that's that's what a lot of the
hitch slaps are uh
and and that's not a um you know to say
this isn't even particularly
a diss on on inches you know i mean i
think you have to
look i mean i said this in the in the
first book you know i think that you
i think that you um that obviously my
particular elaine and what i'm talking
about is trying to get people to be
better at the arguments but like you
want to win
like you all also got to attend to the
way those arguments are rhetorically
packaged there's just
no way around that humans are a
narrative species we just will respond
to that
um so so yeah and then
um i guess as far as the transition to
politics is a little bit complicated
because even in this same era
like uh when you know when somebody like
you know i mean just sticking with
hitchens you know
uh even though like dawkins
certainly was was almost exclusively you
know
was like all anti-religion all the time
pretty much
uh and harris was maybe somewhere in
between
and you know whatever dennis i mean who
watches daddy on youtube
but uh uh
but like christopher hitchens like
during the same period
you know when he was you know it's
certainly true that most of his
his public debates were about religion
because i think that's what there was
the greatest number of people who were
most eager to take him up on it were
but like during the same period
including his brother yeah that's right
uh during the same period that uh that
he was debating you know
doug wilson uh on or
uh tony blair actually uh on uh you know
he didn't debate with tony blair about
whether religion was good for the world
uh
that you know or he so he was doing or
he was doing debates that were allegedly
about the existence of god although
uh i never got the impression that's
what he was really interested in i think
what he always really wanted to get to
was the sort of moral critique of
christianity
uh but during the same period he was
doing this he was also debating
uh george galloway on uh the war in iraq
or for that matter his brother on the
war rocket when he did the thing with
his brother
uh peter hitchens the conservative
writer um
they did it was a it was like a
double-header event and they did a
half-hour debate about
uh iraq and then a half-hour debate
about god uh
and so he was doing these these
political debates at the same time as
the religious ones a lot of people i
think we're fans of both
uh some of which is because people
you know i knew it was up that period of
time
uh you know war on terror jingoism was
pretty popular so you know
it's not surprising it was also popular
among you know
fans of of new atheism although to be
fair there were tons of fans and new
atheism
who certainly weren't on that page at
least about iraq uh
but um but also because some of what
people were were enjoying was just the
performance you know just just the uh
just
just the the rhetorical spectacle uh
all of which the reason i'm emphasizing
it is because when you move on to a
slightly later era
in in this uh this genealogical
progression
uh you get this really weird shift
um which to be fair i don't think
i don't think hitchens would have
participated in uh i mean it's hard to
know of course but but i don't
think i i think it would have just i
think the idw would have just seemed too
tacky for him
uh that's that's that's my best guess uh
i mean honestly the worst version of i
mean i've spent way too much time
thinking about this
the worst version of hitchens that i
could read that i can easily imagine
which i actually do find pretty
plausible is that uh
is that in the last couple years i think
that hitchens might have become just an
absolutely insufferable resistance lib
like he uh i think his his reaction to
uh what happened at the capitol
on january 6 for example probably would
have been very much like his reaction
911 that would be my that would be my
pretty strong guess but
i was just going to chime in quickly
that like even sam harris looks like
he's turned his back on the idw like he
said publicly a few times that he
doesn't want
anything to do with it no no he has like
i think harris eventually got
embarrassed by it because
um because there were other he was
associated with people like the
weinstein brothers
uh you know who were like
trafficking to some extent in trump's
conspiracy theories about the election
and i think that's i think that's a line
you really can't cross
uh with with harris that like you know
you could say maybe we'll have to uh
we'll have to
to uh to new quran and you know that's
fine i mean
you know like he does say in the end of
faith uh but
um but i think like anything that looks
like sympathy for trump
i think um i think you can't like i
think you can't i think basically
to be a little bit mean and caricatured
about it but not i think entirely
inaccurate i don't think you can go to
the cocktail parties that sam harris
wants to go to and say that
so especially after the sixth yeah
especially after this
yeah for sure it's pretty funny to watch
them all scrambling all the idw people
like who've been
who've been playing apologetics for for
all this nonsense and questioning the
election results i don't know
if you've been if you guys have been
partaking in the in the copium of it the
idw refers
to something called the intellectual
dark web there's by the way but a lot of
revisionist history about this but that
is
that is a name that they came up with
for themselves this is a collective
branding exercise they all participated
in
so this is uh the leading lights are
sam harris who we've already discussed
uh jordan peterson
ben shapiro uh brett and eric weinstein
um reuben is reuben
because this this is the weirdest shift
of this is they started
i mean if we're if we can draw this
one-to-one genealogy which i don't know
if we can
i do in my own head so maybe we can
figure it out here but they start off
religion's stupid religion is the thing
that's wrong
with society we need to get religion out
and we're being persecuted because we're
the ones that are saying it
and then whatever it is 13 years later
now like ben shapiro is proudly jewish
reuben's always on about western
civilization
you know see christianity there and then
and then whatever peterson is doing with
his like weird
tradition mystical tradition mixed with
christianity too so we've just had a
complete shift we've had the same
figures doing the same thing
and the emphasis is just uh 180.
yes i think when he was asked straight
up like do you believe in god peterson's
response was
well i'm not sure i can answer that
because there's like 40 different ways
that i have to approach that problem
it's like just answer the [ __ ]
question
yeah the way that peterson will start to
babble on on this on this issue is is
just amazing
that like he um i mean he'll he'll start
like talking about how
you know mathematics needs axioms and
things like that like that that's not a
[ __ ] answer what's wrong with it
but um but yeah so
in fact actually there's a really
revealing uh clip
of dave rubin interviewing together
uh jordan peterson and ben shapiro and
he's asking them about their belief in
god i think
um uh you know i think
i think reuben might even officially be
an agnostic or something i'm not sure
but uh he uh but he's he's asking them
about why they believe in god and you
know in this context at least peterson
runs with it as if he does and
um and it is like just amazing what the
difference is between
between their answers because
like ben shapiro talks about why he
believes in god like you know whatever
like a
i think not particularly interesting or
insightful but like somebody who
is sort of like recognizably uh a
variation of like a
kind of normal right-wing intellectual
like he does like he
i mean he gives like a kind of very
like it's like very um
you know like he kind of gives some like
variation of like aquinas's first way or
something but it's like a very
straightforward answer
uh and you know whatever we can dunk on
him for that if we want you know i mean
i think it's certainly
one of those cases much like the san
hara stuff we were talking about
where there are extremely obvious
objections that some people have
sophisticated answers to but you know
shapiro doesn't even seem to know about
the objection
but whatever that was his answer not
that interesting peterson's answer
sounded like notes that you would take
as like
um like as you were like
you were coming down from like a
particularly like intense acid trip
where you thought you had a religious
experience
like it's just it's it's just total
gibberish about like the was it the
masculine principle he senses evolution
and blah blah blah blah blah somehow
there's that means there's a god
uh so so yeah but i think certainly
harris is
like the fact that sam harris was both a
member of the new atheist four horsemen
and then a member of the intellectual
dark web uh
is is really interesting right because
as you say
the whole point of the four horsemen was
anti-religion and
uh ben shapiro i mean we can go a step
beyond probably jewish he
he's a like he's he's just a straight-up
fundamentalist he said
uh he's you know he's like a um
you know like there can't be a
palestinian state because god gave
israel the jewish people right i mean
like he's that kind of
you know believer uh and
and jordan peterson is is some kind of
you know incredible like weird mystical
guru basically
uh and somehow uh harris
is is in the same club as these guys
right after
after being a new atheist of course you
can say okay that's the eccentricity of
sam harris and you know like what he's
interested in or what
you know cultural war things
preoccupying him at any given time
but then i think the thing that really
gets the heart of your question is
my strong impression is that tons of
people followed him right like like on a
grassroots level i think
a lot of people who were who were new
atheist fans
became idw fans and on the surface it
just makes no
no sense whatsoever i can tell you by
reading gad's ads that there is an
answer
which is that a lot of them regard
social justice warriors as a new kind of
religion
yeah and i think that's temperamentally
why they when we can get into this in
more detail but i think that's terrible
kind of religion against it so you know
whatever there's there's some
continuities around things like
islamophobia too
like that played a big role in new
atheism and now now it plays a similar
a different kind of role but it's still
like the inferior religion so whatever
judeo-christian traditions are better
there's some continuities but then the
things come to play different roles in
the new sort of configuration and the
idw
and as you know like shapiro and
peterson both aren't
averse to trying to point out uh trying
to appeal to
the logic reason facts don't care about
your feelings type uh
where applause which is interesting yeah
like evolution could play the basis for
an atheist argument
in dawkins view and then evolution could
play a
role mystical enforcing traditional
gender roles in the new sort of idw
peterson the same bits can just kind of
move into the new sphere
and play different roles but like
content-wise they look almost identical
but you have to look at how they're
what work they're now doing in the new
context yeah
so that that's right so like uh like
like michael brooks's book against the
web you know one of one of the big
structure and things
is that um you know conservatives
are all like you know at their their
base you know about defending
traditional hierarchies and they tend to
do this in two ways
uh either um you know mythologizing
or uh or naturalizing so you know so
uh where where the left would want to
historicize in other words you know
uh into like show how things can you
know
like came about in the first place so
they're they're they contingently happen
to exist but they don't have to
uh the the the right wants to either
mythologize or naturalize so it wants to
either
uh tell um you know tell some sort of
like scientific story that's supposed to
supposed to justify these things that oh
it's just you know
it's just part of nature uh or um
which which of course what you know is
what sam harris you know
will do that's his lane uh or it's
it's going to mythologize them you know
which of course is the the older and
historically more popular right-wing
strategy
uh and the really interesting thing
about peterson
is that he just constantly goes back and
forth between the two strategies he does
both all the time
that he uh that he's he's both going to
talk about like
like evolution and how you know we have
uh you know serotonin exists and
lobsters and therefore we can't have
socialism or whatever
um
i don't know why i found that so funny i
think i've heard that show before and
then
but then he's also going to do like you
know it's gonna be both right so
it's gonna be like oh you know there's
the you know
lobster evolution argument you know but
then it's also gonna be that you know
you have to like have traditional
hierarchy to you know keep the dragon of
chaos at bay
yeah he he does the same thing with his
it's sort of like a social darwinism
if you look back all all societies have
a myth of
of the originary feminine being
conquered by the original
masculine and that to him has no
contradiction with his
you know serotonin levels argument yeah
clearly adopted from delusion guterres
double articulation lobster of the
double articulation of good and evil and
male and female
or chaos and order yeah and of course um
one thing that's always worth pointing
out here it's a very small point but
it's it's one that gets to me is that uh
he's not even getting the mythology
right
like uh there was a uh current affairs
did a article
i think it was light of gold uh it's
just called like a current affairs
mythology quiz or something like that
but she's just having a lot of fun like
going through like all of the
counter examples and different
mythologies to you know
like what he'll say or the universal
archetypes that are present you know
literally
literally everywhere and it's like well
no
i mean a lot of this stuff like come on
like who
who's more um like this this idea
that like the uh the masculine
principles universally associated with
order the feminine one with chaos
okay like really seriously if you're
gonna make this this like
universal car cultural archetype claim
here right
who's more um you know like
who's more chaotic zeus or hera come on
like who's who who's who's more you know
who's more chaotic marge simpson or
homer simpson
like there are tons you know there are
tons
of of of counter examples to all of his
claims
about mythology he's just cherry-picking
the stuff that you know that fits this
the story that sounds right to him
and of course that's even more true with
the the evolution stuff that he that
um like if you watch like pz myers
uh is uh who actually it's funny
um sir peasy myers is a biologist and he
uh and a blogger and somebody who was
sort of a minor figure in the new
atheism era
um but i on on twitter once i referred
to him
as the uh the best of the old new
atheist crowd and he actually responded
to the tweet
and said uh and and said that that was
that was
uh you know dabbing with faint praise
you know since he he now feels
embarrassed for having associated with
him but he has
uh but like myers like has has some
videos where he's just taking apart like
all of the ways in which peterson's
claims about these things are just
bizarrely scientifically inaccurate
because because there too he's still
cherry-picking but like at least if
you're cherry-picking mythology it's
pretty easy to at least read about all
that stuff
whereas with anything that involves
actual expert knowledge you know when
you're doing your weird cherry picky
read of it
you know the same thing will happen so i
guess
uh i guess long story short i think that
uh i think that
a lot of what's going on there is that
a lot well i think what we found out
with this shift
is that a lot of people didn't really
like new atheism for the atheism they
didn't care that much about it
right they uh they like new atheism
uh for
a certain kind of aggressive rhetorical
style that they enjoyed
being deployed against people that they
considered to be cultural enemies
dare i say that it was feelings about
it yeah
is why they care about this right
because it doesn't matter
whether it's it's like um
yeah it doesn't matter whether uh you
know whether
it's uh you know it's it's christopher
hitchens who
you know at the base of his world view
is like still sort of a marxist and
is uh uh and like has some like terrible
neoconservative foreign policy positions
and you know and and the main thing
they're enjoying about him is the
atheism
or if it's uh it's jordan peterson who's
like
some like freakish cross reincarnation
of william f buckley and ron das in his
world view
because uh like even though these things
are
completely incompatible on the surface
people who enjoy them have a certain
set of cultural preoccupations and
perceived enemies
and yeah maybe like you know snake
handling you know southern baptist might
be one of them
or i guess the pentecostals who handle
the snakes
but uh but like feminists are certainly
one of them
uh you know campus sjw types
are certainly one of them uh and
so anybody who's like anybody who's
deploying even though right like it's
completely bizarre to do
like i mean the fact that so many fans
of jordan peterson are so trained
with this logic and reason and facts
rhetoric
that they'll even apply to it like when
they respond to criticisms of peter says
it's like oh but what about his argument
and then you're like
what what [ __ ] argument are you
talking about like you actually read
that you actually watch the video where
they say what about his argument
and his argument is like well i had a
dream where i saw three snakes and an
elephant to you know
what i got out of that you know like
there's no argument it's it's
it's just like pure like mystical you
know babble
but he has an accent it's not the same
accent as the one we were talking about
but it helps
um his canadian his like albertan
canadian accent
well yeah i didn't i didn't notice yeah
accent does he speaks normally he has a
slight one
muppet accent just sounds like he's on
friends or something like that not not
so
joey but he could be like ross i don't
know but that's that
so that does what that does that that
whole
oh yeah if you go ahead no it's gonna
say look the accent helps
uh the fact that he he sounds really
really sure of himself
helps uh and then he's
and then he's spitting he's spitting
fire at people who they perceive to be
on the other side of cultural battle
lines for them
and that's ultimately what they value
you know so even if it's
you know i mean even if it's ben shapiro
who
uh you know who would like surely be
who you know is yeah has some like
fundamentalist religious views
climate denier et cetera et cetera like
he is like on paper the guy who would
have been the enemy
in you know 2007 you know from uh the
four horsemen
uh but he speaks really quickly he
sounds very confident
and he he delivers what you know
whatever
i mean as a matter of taste it doesn't
do much for me but they consider to be
like really good you know rhetorical
smackdowns of people they think of as
their enemies
and so that's good enough to count him
as a champion of you know logic and
reason
i should say also that there's one other
thing that i think contributes to it
which is the cult of personality that
surrounds a lot of these figures
which they do a lot to cultivate i mean
if you look at the beginning of maps of
meeting
it's essentially an autobiography uh
where he very humbly uh opens the book
with i will now utter truths that have
been hidden into
uh so far from the foundations of the
earth which is quote from the bible
and includes a letter from his to his
dad saying i've now realized things that
no one else has understood before and
it's so big that i can only get a
glimpse of it
uh by the way thanks for paying my
income taxes and you know moves on from
there
same thing with gad sad right gadzad you
know describes himself as genius you
know blah blah blah
in many different ways that's totally
right like there's a uh
i was just listening uh last weekend
uh to a discussion from uh 2018
uh between uh michael brooks and uh
thaddeus russell
who from the um unregistered podcast
and you know they disagree about tons of
stuff but they do agree about the guys
we're talking about
and there's like a really yeah there's
like a really perceptive moment in that
conversation where michael is saying
well
you know look i'm not gonna lie i i
i i enjoy being praised i enjoy
you know fans all that stuff right
but i wouldn't want to have fans the way
these guys have fans like that
i was curious about um you know your own
experiences
um engaging with with people who are
maybe idw sympathetic
and also like maybe give some comment on
what i perceive as one one of the things
from a political perspective is it kind
of seems like the left was a little bit
late to the party
like to some extent like with with
online media right and to some extent i
think what you're doing
to some extent like what we're doing too
at this point for this podcast is
i feel like we're addressing potentially
some audience that was
like a little bit um tempted or seduced
by idw types or some of these other
online people like stefan molyneux and i
feel like
more emerging voices like yourselves uh
and ours
is you know to some extent maybe winning
some of these people back and i wonder
what that experience has been like for
you maybe
with some of the debates you've done and
maybe like an anecd if you have an
anecdote too about people who have you
know messaged you like what what
what if if you do have people who
message you on a regular basis who said
you know oh i used to believe
this but seeing your videos we actually
get that a lot
and we got that we get that quite a bit
yeah i used to be
i used to watch all of jordan peterson's
videos so now i watch all of yours
like well i don't know if that's much
better but yeah i had i had a former
richard spencer fan like like to like
message me on twitter being like you
know i'm quite i used to love richard
spencer but now like i just listen to
you guys all the time so it's
a step in the right direction for sure i
want to interject and say that like
all my four is onto the internet
everything that i've done thus far was
really just a desperate cry for more of
eric in my life
and i finally caught all of the stuff
that i why are we why are we back at
this
yeah let's not let's not bring that up
yeah yeah ben it's just an ongoing joke
that for some reason for some reason
matt just uh has like
a lot of sexual seduction to eric i
don't know why
our love will blossom through the cogs
of this machine no matter what you try
to do
exactly don't let them stop us baby yeah
yeah fair enough
um
[Laughter]
um yeah look i mean i get messages like
that
i mean i don't know yeah i think it's
like a reasonable trickle you know that
that happens
you know that happens over time uh
and i think that yeah i think it's
tricky because i think
when you say you talk about the left
being late to uh to catch up with that
uh i think there is a structural reason
for that um
and even though obviously the situation
has gotten much better i don't think
that reason's gone away
uh which is that in a way i mean
ironically
it's actually just a version of like the
same old like
uh noam chomsky on cnn problem which is
um i remember you know there's there's
this uh documentary
um uh yeah there's a documentary about
chomsky called manufacturing consent
uh which i remember used to have the uh
it was like a two vhs's rubber banded
together
uh you know of of that uh i'm very old
be kind please rewind i remember i
remember those days
yeah uh and and there's a point in there
where where he makes this really
perceptive comment which is that
uh actually it would um it would be a
better propaganda
uh for uh for mainstream outlets it
would be it would be
you know like if they were smarter or
they would have people like
him on all the time because in a 30
second sound bite you know if he
if he said the things that he thinks uh
he'd sound like a lunatic and it would
be like a good you know
it'd be a good way to discredit him and
of course
on paper uh the youtube era the twitch
era you know you mentioned destiny
earlier
uh is a is a great way you know
is like a you know sounds like this is
great we won't have that problem anymore
because
look i mean you can i mean you can dub
anything onto youtube you know like you
could have
like if if you want like a six hour long
explanation
of whatever the hell right you know you
can do that uh
but i think the um
you know the market incentives you know
certainly aren't going to uh to favor
that
and especially the kind of thing we're
talking about before
you know the ownage uh is something
that is a lot easier to do when you're
catering to views that people
already kind of have uh that if you if
you want to just do that like quick like
rhetorical
like slapping down uh of
of the opposition then it's a lot easier
to do that if
if people already have some pretty
sympathetic sense of where you're coming
from
uh now there are people who are going to
just be fans of the
the art form and so they'll they'll be
able to recognize when someone does a
good one even when they don't like where
they're coming from and that might even
make them think about where they're
coming from
and then i come around that happens uh
but i i also think that to a great
extent
um i don't know i mean this is something
to struggle with because
i i think that trying to go on the
particular
you know civilizing mission that i've
been trying to go on you know since i
wrote the book and
have done all these you know debates and
stuff um
is trying to do two things at once uh
and it'd be a lot
it would be a lot easier without doing
both of them at once
which are are one like you know putting
certain
views out there and uh and you know
arguing against other views but then
also
too trying to get people to
like trying to actually change their
tastes for how to talk about this stuff
uh so to to not only say better things
but to say them in a better way
and to try to get people to come along
with you on saying them in a better or
better way and to sort of
um like yeah develop this this taste for
something that's not
that ten second slap down uh
but that is actually making them think
and uh
and as is making distinctions and making
arguments and you know and all of that
stuff uh which is not what
i think the media most naturally rewards
which means that if you are gonna try to
do this
these things then you have to strike a
certain kind of balance uh that you
um you know because it can't be all that
all the time you know you're gonna lose
the audience
uh so i i think you need to both
try to give people a sense of why
the uh the long version is worthwhile
uh but also you know you you have to
like you do have to accept
that on a certain level it's it's it's
you know rhetorical pro wrestling and
just
sounding very forceful and having good
lines and all that stuff
i mean you just can't completely get
past those things so i
i don't know if i don't know if what i
do is a like
um awkward compromise between these
imperatives that that actually
that actually works or one that uh or
one that that doesn't quite succeed in
any of them i mean i will say i do get
those those emails and dms so it
certainly works for some people
uh but it's it's a uh but it's it's a
tricky tightrope to try to walk for sure
almost like you can you can never
actually tell
just just from the example we already
used of
the new atheists now becoming whatever
quasi historical mystical
christians is that it's never really
about the facts
anyway it's entirely about feelings
and i think it's what you're describing
is you're trying to appeal to
facts while at the same time
participating in a medium that very
obviously rewards
feelings i actually had a comment uh
that related to that and then a question
um it's actually restlessly on the last
thing i said actually because
while i do also sometimes get those
emails which are always very endearing
90 of the stuff that i get is very
critical and i don't know if any of you
have noticed this but
it's very unusual since a lot of these
people tend to be right-wing
fundamentalists and yet the language
they use
is almost always so homoerotically
charged
it's like yeah i can't believe this if
you like i wrote a review of ben
shapiro's book and i got emails from
people
like if he were here he would have
[ __ ] ass raped you [ __ ] you know i
was like
fundamentalist you know orthodox jew i'm
not really sure you should be ass raping
me at all you know it's just
it's a bit of a thing about it
yeah some fantasy projections going on
there my one question actually is that
koi robin wrote about this both in his
book and uh he's continued to do this
where he says
the right going back to people like
edmund burke i would actually even go
further saying
uh back to people um like um
some of the early uh catholic
reactionaries to modernity has always
tried to cultivate what he called this
bad boy image but a very superficial bad
boy image
uh and you see this carrying on to like
the present day with people like paul
joseph watson he had this
infamous quote uh in the middle of the
2010s where he said
conservatism is the new counter culture
and you know robin points out that this
is always really problematic since the
kind of things that they try to defend
aren't really very bad boy you know it's
things like wow we need more police and
we need more order and
you know we should people should read
the classics that kind of stuff we need
strong marriages between a man and a
woman
yeah exactly so subversive
uh i mean look i remember trying to
remember who wrote it but my
my favorite comment on uh the uh the
rise and fall of
milo yabba oh exactly yeah he's a great
biz
uh had um you know
said like it is remarkable because like
once you sort of peel back
all of the bluster and uh
and and the uh and the sort of talking
about how much he loved black [ __ ]
and all that stuff uh then
all the action all the actual opinions
that milo works was expressing were i
mean this was a british writer so i
think the way he put it were like
indistinguishable from the opinions of
like your boring home county's dad you
know
pushing around you know that the peas
and gravy on the on the plate while he's
you know ranting about foreigners
yeah or foreign food yeah yeah yeah he
does
uh like he doesn't have we need good
form we need good british food like you
know
curry and tea blood pudding yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i mean that's this is um this
is by the way why i'm enthusiastically
in favor of cultural appropriation i
think the idea of like telling like
british people
that they actually have to eat
indigenous british food is too cruel to
do to anybody
water's on a human rights violation well
this is why they have such terrible
teeth as there's no like actual
nutrients in
pudding putting in potatoes so then like
in milo yiannopoulos case uh the the
particularly hilarious thing about this
now i know some people
on the left try to like tell themselves
that they did something that caused
the downfall of of milo is like oh no it
was all the like you know yelling him on
campus that's what made him go away
total [ __ ] right like what like he
was he was riding strong
on that wave of their hatred which was
his entire marketing gimmick that's what
his career was built on
uh was the you know left attempts to
de-platform him what
caused his downfall was that after
all the years of expressing totally
boring conservative opinion while
going on and on and on and on and on
about what a bad boy he was and how his
thoughts were too dangerous for anybody
to accept them
uh he finally actually said something
that conservatives were offended by and
then they all dropped him
immediately you know they they canceled
his
you know he lost his book contract he
lost his cpap you know uh
uh cpac you know speaking and you know
speaking engagement you know the
conservative movement
now no longer what it did to have
anything to do with him uh
because um you know he'd he made some
comments about the ambiguities of age
and consent you know and
uh in his uh his own sexual awakening
and in the gay community and there was
like
nope sorry sorry buddy that's that's too
far i can't do that
uh so so yeah i think that's i think
that's absolutely right
um and
[Music]
yeah they they do they do try you know
they do try this act
uh and yeah i do get those emails i do
get some of the emails that matt is
talking about too you know like like not
apparently you know not quite like he's
describing i i
just write just write a review of one of
ben shapiro's books and believe me
they will come even just say you're
going to write a review of it and
they'll kind of
i'm just saying you know people seem to
be much more interested in raping matt's
ass than mine i don't know what's
happening
you got to cultivate the right arms
we've only heard this from matt himself
too no one has actually seen the emails
so
i'll try not to be too offended but uh
in any case
um but like i actually got like uh
a few of these uh just a couple weeks
ago
uh not again quite like that but uh but
but of you know but a little bit of
like a little wave of hate mail because
i wrote this uh this jacobin article
called uh abolish inherited wealth and
people
uh and several people actually cared
enough to track down
my my day job email address to uh to
send me hate mail about it
uh which um which yeah is is also
impressive in
in very much the way that we were
talking about because
like all of the people like all of these
emails
are by people who who fetishize like the
rhetoric of logic and reason
uh but uh there's no there's nothing
that looks like an argument anywhere in
sight right you know
it's just it's just that i'm wrong
therefore you know like
i have a conclusion that's different
from their conclusion therefore i'm
irrational
therefore i must be indoctrinating
college students you know with my
irrational beliefs
uh you know like like that that that's
just the truth that's just the train of
thought there
and and i guess i i do also want to just
briefly go back to the question
about um you know the feels and the
reels because i think that
i think that the good thing the one good
thing here as far as the problem that
we're talking about
about the left sort of competing in a
medium that really rewards
um reinforcing ideas that are already in
people's heads
is that it's not just about trying to
get people to care about facts
that this is where i think a little bit
of david hume actually goes a long way
because
of course you know when they say oh
we're deriving our our political
conclusions from the facts
you know not feelings uh this is not
only just
you know hilariously untrue about them
but it's also impossible right you you
can't derive normative conclusions
uh purely from from facts the uh that
you know there's a uh this is a gap
right i mean the like facts can only be
relevant to conclusions about
you know morality or politics or what we
should do
if they're accompanied by some sort of
relevant principle right you know
a uh uh you know the
fetus being a you know human life from
the moment of conception or whatever
uh is only relevant to to any sort of
anti-abortion
uh you know political conclusion if you
also have the premise that
uh that anything that is you know
anything that's biologically a human
life you know has
uh has a moral right to life uh and
and the good thing about this is that
that means that there is something that
we could that we could appeal to and and
i think this actually gets it
something that people are often confused
about because they said well hold on how
can you you know
how can you debate you know whatever
stefan molyneux right you know he's a
complete lunatic you don't share any of
the same
you know goals or premises so so what's
what's the common ground and what uh
which there is to argue about anything
you know which is a fair question
uh but i think that part of the answer
is that one of the goals of arguing with
somebody like stefan molyneux
is to get him to bite certain bullets
that are going to show
that in a very deep way uh he doesn't
share
the sort of basic moral intuitions that
nearly all human beings will and this
is thus going to make him less appealing
to anybody to whom parts of what he was
saying sound good but then when you get
to the letting poor people down and
starve to death in the street
i think that anybody who's gettable in
his audience could be like wait a second
i don't like that
yeah i mean my my take on that those the
hate mail is probably
goes back to saying youtube's role and
um
in this rise of this debate lordism is
that those and those nice little
packaged uh like slaps you get
like that that aestheticizing of of
logic and debate
as opposed to like it's more substantial
core
it aestheticizes it and that
aestheticization really gives itself to
polarization because it's it's a lot
like when it when a you know when a kid
goes and sees like a batman do a cool
thing and then he wants to run out and
dress up as batman do the same cool
thing like those
they play a similar role people want to
imitate so this aestheticization
leads to this or like feeds into a kind
of
polarization and then people have these
fantasies i mean i
i have them too of you know someone's
walking into a point that you're
prepared and then you have this great
comeback for them and
and hate mail is just like that but
rehearsal so you get to like
i get to i get to strawman their
argument and then beat it to [ __ ] and
i mean it's kind of a fantasy
fulfillment every night there's
thousands of
20 year olds practicing owning feminists
in front of their mirror
it's empty that's the point of like
aestheticizing politics and debate
and religion is is to make it kind of
empty and and flat
whereas politicizing is the opposite
i mean at this point i have a standard
response to the hate mail which is
not constructive but like you know
whatever you either ignore it or you
respond in a way that's not constructive
uh so i just have like a little thing
that i copy and paste that's like hey
there champ
uh glad to uh glad to see that my
article made you think so much
uh you know keep reading
yeah that's why i appreciate your move
and and others to make
like logic seem like a more substantial
thing that you have to slow down and
kind of think about it's not just this
is a sort of
show like another part of our genealogy
should probably be
like even going back to the days of
abelard where he conceived of himself
as at war with other people and battling
other people and all this
military language is very much built
into logic
and it comes out in weird ways in this
aestheticized world we live in now is
because you're
undermining somebody's argument or
you're retreating to defend a position
you're
attacking somebody's points like all of
this military language
is like deep deep in logic as well you
talk a lot about that in your book very
effectively also and i mean we've all
encountered this on twitter right where
you got there what'd you call them the
logic bros right who
pretty much treat any kind of twitter
interaction like combat right and
they're just eager to throw out
all this complicated sound and
terminology like no you're committing a
martin bailey no you're committing an
appeal to authority and
how did you describe it it was almost
like point checking right
no that's that's right uh which which of
course is also
um i mean the way that these guys
you know and look i mean i'll say that
the
the sort of logic probably described in
the book like as an archetype various
people
you know uh fit to varying extents you
know i don't know how many pure examples
there are but you know there are
certainly people who do act like this to
one extent or another
and it's and then i think the
frustrating thing
is that this also reinforces um
the the impulse of some people who um
you know who have good politics you know
to uh just to be very dismissive you
know about
uh about certain kinds of logic talk
because they're
they you know they associate it with
these [ __ ] and also
like they they correctly sense that what
people like this
are doing with this logical terminology
is not
actually something that they have any
reason to take seriously because
uh because what they're doing and i
think both people like this who
fetishize the rhetoric of logic and also
people who who are maybe way too quick
to to roll their eyes at you know
logical terminology
what they have in common is that like
what they think that it is
to diagnose something as committing a
logical fallacy
is like handing out a yellow card in a
debate you know that like oh you you
broke the rules
uh and the rules seem seem arbitrary
right
it's it's almost like you know this is
like there was it's like the
marquis of you know queensberry rules
you know for a gentlemanly debate or
something you know it's like what
what's the uh like you know because like
if these
fallacies we shall pause and have a
glass of wine in between
yeah exactly if the fallacies are what
these people say they are
right then like why would anybody care
about them you know like like if it's
if like uh ever saying anything you know
uh you know if they ever say anything
mean about somebody is ad hominem or
whatever you know that it's like okay
well
i mean it should be obvious to anybody
thinks about that for three seconds that
that doesn't actually mean that you're
like um that actually that doesn't
actually mean that your argument is
defective in any way you know that like
if you're rude about it you know or that
like you can't
um like say something you know like
there might be lots of reasons not to
you know that are good reasons you know
that it's it's
it's unkind or unconstructive or
whatever but
uh it's certainly not a logical fallacy
you know that they
like like the way that people tend to
talk about logical fallacies online
is just that these are things that for
some
reason that must just be convention or
something or just kind of against the
rules
uh and and people will will often say
like
people often say that you're a committee
of fallacy when you're literally not
even making an argument of any kind you
know fallacious or otherwise
that you know you just got to say
something and they say oh well you know
that's a fallacy or you know oh where's
your argument it's like no i
i i'm not i'm not pretending to give you
an argument
i'm just i'm just saying something right
like nine you know 99.999
of human speech acts uh aren't
accompanied by
explicit arguments and it'd be really
weird if they were
yeah i mean if i call you a dumbass then
you're probably too dumb to actually
understand my argument anyway so
we're just going to leave it at you're a
dumb ass and that's what it is right
yeah yeah exactly like like i i can just
like it could just be
like yeah i mean i could say something
unkind about you before or after
you know addressing your argument
ooh coven's acting up uh or uh
uh or i could or i could just do it you
know instead because maybe i just don't
even think that they
like i just don't even think the
argument's worth engaging with
um and and none of that is uh
is committing any sort of uh any sort of
logical fallacy you know like maybe i've
missed an opportunity if you said
something
that i should have engaged with uh but
you know but like what what ad hominem
for example means
is that you've treated an irrelevant
negative
claim right true or false you know an
irrelevant negative claim about
the speaker as a reason to think that
their
conclusion is wrong or their argument is
bad you know uh like
um you know carl uh
you know karl marx uh you know sometimes
used you know casually bigoted language
and correspondence with you know
frederick ingles therefore
uh you know therefore you know marxism
is a bad
theory of history or economics right you
know like that's that's the ad hominem
fallacy but of course that's that's much
less exciting because like once you
once you understand it that way uh
you're not gonna be able to accuse
people of it 200 times a day
you know because because the you know
like actual
crystal clear examples of it uh are
relatively few and far between
uh and more generally you know what you
should like
if the point the reason that a logical
fallacy is bad is not that this is just
somehow uncouth ways to you know act and
debate
but the reason that it's bad is that
these are just bad ways to reason that
they're they're not going to uh
you know they're not gonna get you with
the truth uh
then the way that you should you know
that you should respond to
uh say somebody saying you know you're
um
oh you know you're committed this
fallacy or whatever is to like think
about it for a while and say i don't
know maybe
is it you know is is there you know if i
like is there a different way i could
you know could like construe the
argument you know so so it's maybe not
uh and and of course that's uh that's
very bad television you know
that like that's that's not really you
know it's not really conducive to being
included in the hitch slap compilation
all right i'd like to uh give you the
concluding question because we're
we're at time um but in light of
the first two weeks of uh 2021
in light of a four year biden presidency
we've kind of been banging around the
idea in here that it is in fact
not time to change the world it is in
fact time to
think about the world but as someone who
is emblematic of the online left and has
had
most of the online left on your channel
what do you think the purpose of this
kind of internet
stuff politics is under a four-year
regime of a daughtering old uh
you know jell-o-brained jell-o brain
centrist
yeah well i mean i guess in a very
immediate sense
uh i think that i think that some of it
is just
to uh to keep up uh the uh
the the critique of of not only the
jello brain centrists but you know but
but centrism
uh that there there is a great danger
you know with the democrat and power
of um you know there's a there's a
gravitational pull
towards uh towards just collapsing back
into regular centrist liberalism
you know because the um
i mean maybe i don't know maybe more
maybe less debatable but you know but in
a different way
you know then that was trump as
president uh because
um because the real problem
i think the i you know i don't want to
say the
or you know probably not even the top
ten but a big problem for the left
uh is that it's very easy to get sucked
into the poll
of politics as um
you know liberals versus the right so uh
you you want
so for example you'd be you know you'd
be defending
you know biden and the democrats against
you know whatever crazy [ __ ] you know
that
uh you know glenn becker whoever is
saying about them
uh and and that's that's tricky because
i think we had a window from from 2015
to 2020 where um
it was a little bit more obvious how to
do politics outside of that space
uh because the the two bernie sanders
campaigns for president bookend in that
like really created that that space to
the left of liberalism as something that
felt like
you know like really obvious and there
and like something you can easily
explain to anybody
right you know like hey yeah i don't
look bad and i'm a birdie guy you know
like uh
and and now that's gone and
so i think that they're going to be i
think there's the danger of collapsing
back into liberalism i think there's the
danger of overcompensating
by you know becoming uh you know
people's front for the liberation of
judea you know ultra left uh
you know in your effort to to to like
overdo it improving what a leftist you
are
um so i think that one thing that left
media can do
is help orient people ideologically
which
is is important
although i guess the one other
distinction that i would make
is that i think we need to get be really
clear
about the respect in which it's
important uh
and this is something that um
you know maybe you guys were you know
sort of blissfully
you know uh not interacting with this
nonsense but
um but i think that there's a whole
weird thing that happened from like late
december to
early january um where
in certain kinds of left media spaces
and online left spaces
there was this like bizarre like month
of people being like furious that
alexandria ocasio-cortez wasn't doing
this like really specific like media
stunt
that uh this this comedian and podcaster
jimmy dora came up with that he wanted
her to do
and you know without relitigating uh
that nightmare i would say that
one one thing that it really taught me
is
that we've got a big problem with people
not being clear about the distinction
between politics and talking about
politics
and making that distinction i don't i'm
not at all saying obviously
that talking about politics is
unimportant you know it has no value
i clearly do think it has value or i
wouldn't be doing it
uh but it's just not the same thing so
politics is what you're doing when
you're
doing things like um you know
organizing a labor union in the
workplace or uh
or or doing an electoral campaign
or you know going you know door to door
to try to do some sort of
you know medicare for all candidacy
that's politics
uh just voting once every four years
yeah not just you know
that too right but certainly not just
that right like that's politics
uh but this isn't politics this is
talking about politics
and talking about politics can play all
sorts of useful
support roles for for a left political
project
um it can you know certainly provide
political education it can provide
inspiration
um can provide entertainment which see
above you know the rest of the
conversation is a big part of what's
being provided and you know there's no
getting away from that
that that is an essential component you
know of of what it provides
uh and it can you know if things
go really well the best cases it can
provide
ideological and strategic clarification
and these are all things
that a viable left project in the real
world needs
but they aren't the thing itself
uh they you know they the support the
support systems for
the left in the real world can't be
mistaken uh
for for the actual the actual left you
know it's it's this is not like
you know listening um you know listening
to chapo trap house
uh is not actually you know being
engaged in politics
uh even going on reddit to yell at the
chapel hosts it's not politics you know
the uh
uh you know politics is something that
you have to actually log off to do which
i know it's not in my interest to
encourage people to do that
but um but then you know that is what
you have to ultimately do right like you
know you can get
you you can get i think a useful
perspective online that's going to help
you in many ways perhaps as you do with
that
but the doing of the thing itself is
separate
and i don't pretend to have the answers
but i'm i'm
it's something i've been much more
cognizant of lately the sort of need to
try to make that distinction
uh distinction clear to people but yeah
i mean look i think
i think i think you know doing stuff
like you know like like this podcast
like whatever
i think can uh can help people you know
i think if we are entering into
something of a period of retreat for the
left
uh which i hope we aren't but we might
be uh then i think it can help you
maintain a sense of perspective uh and
and there's there's some real value in
that you know to to help people
stay in it for the long haul which is
important because i think one of the
real problems with the online left and
left media spaces
is that we tend to get really excited
about transitory things and burning to
burn ourselves out
uh and and that's you know you're just
not gonna be any good to anybody if you
do that so i think that i think the
sense of community can be valuable i
think
i think uh i think just sort of having a
sense of the long haul can be valuable
and uh and yeah i i think that i think
that
thinking about thinking
can obviously be very useful for
changing the world just
you know just just my pitches you know i
mean the um
if you've ever seen the movie the young
karl marx uh there's a great scene in it
where uh marx and engels are like
stumbling home drunk and like i think
one of them is like vomiting in an
alleyway and uh
and that's that's the moment when the
movie has marks you know come up with
the line from the
thesis on firebach about how the point
is to change it
uh but uh regardless of where i came up
with it you know he is right
all right thank you that is as as
articulate
of an answer to that question as we've
ever had on this podcast and that's for
sure
yeah um so on behalf of pills
eric victor and matt thank you so much
ben
for dropping by uh ben if you like what
he's talking about
he's got a podcast and a youtube channel
full of
do you do you tran or are they the
actual
videos of you recording the podcast on
there are they two separate things uh no
no the actual videos are uh are on there
so it's it's there's
um the the show
airs uh live on youtube
on monday nights at 7 30 eastern
uh and then the uh the next day or you
know later that night you know it comes
out in uh
in in audio form on the podcast feed so
i mean i'm probably showing my age and
even always referring to it as the
podcast because i sort of
instinctively think of that as the
primary form that these things take but
uh but but it is at least as much so a
youtube channel do you always do it live
uh yeah we do now it wasn't original no
that's cool but yeah but now it's
we should do that sometime yep yeah it's
fun yeah you get to interact with the
audience you know it's yeah it's good
stuff
all right it is ben burgess from give
them an argument
and uh from all of us thanks a lot and
we will
speak at you later thank you yeah thanks
man
third time hopefully yeah yeah probably
see the word
all right the map is not the territory
all right cool i'm still
reeling from the finding out that uh
jordan peterson has an accent
a nation of kermit the frogs up here
like what the [ __ ]